these are no ordinary musicians French
juggling days of Javan own drop their
balls for this gasoline display of
tubular talent and it's hit the right
note with over 1 and a half million
people online if it was up to me this
would be number one of every episode but
how do these jugglers turn simple hollow
tubes from blah to beast mode when one
of their hands hits the tube it gives
the air inside the tube extra energy
those air molecules start moving towards
the ends of the tube that creates an
area of low pressure in the middle of
the tube it pulls those air molecules
back in of course then they start moving
back out and in and you've created a
bouncy stretchy vibrating column of air
they set up what's called a standing
wave this standing wave sets up another
vibration outside the ends of the tube
and that vibration is one that we can
hear as a musical note to make a song we
need more than one note and so the tubes
have been carefully cut to be just the
right length to give us different tones
the red one gives us to see the yellow
one gives us an E which means this
musical masterclass is based on some
science they've had to learn every
single move off by heart and get it
absolutely perfect in the right place at
the right time that is a huge
achievement